[موسيقى]
طلبت ايران من تركيا وقطر المساعده في
الافراج عن 8 ايرانيا قالت انهم زوار
اختطفهم مسلحون في منطقه السيده زينب بريف
دمشق لكن مصدرا في الجيش السوري الحر قال
ان المحتجزين عناصر من الحرس الثوري
الايراني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والشبح
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين ما
الذي حمل الجيش السوري الحر على احتجاز
هؤلاء الزوار والتشكيك في دوافع قدومهم
وعلى اي وجه يمكن ان تنعكس هذه الحادثه
على الدور الايراني المثير للجدل في
[موسيقى]
سوريا
السلام عليكم وتقبل الله
صومكم الجدل الذي يلف الدور الايراني في
سوريا يخيم بكثافه على مصير 48 ايرانيا
تقول طهران انهم زوار كانوا متوجهين الى
مقام السيده زينب قبل اختطافهم في منطقه
ريف دمشق بينما يقول الجيش السوري الحر ان
المحتجزين مقاتلون من الشبيحه بينهم ضباط
في الحرس الثوري الايراني تهمه تحيل
بدورها الى مجموعه ايرانيه اخ اخرى احتجزت
قبل ايام في ليبيا مثل ما تحيل الى كشف
اليمن الشهر الماضي عما قالت انه خليه
تجسس ايرانيه تعمل في البلاد منذ سبع
سنوات ايرانيون في قبضه جماعات مسلحه
مناهضه للنظام السوري ذاك ما اعلنته
السفاره الايرانيه في دمشق مؤكده ان 48
زائرا من رعاياها تعرضوا للاختطاف وهم في
طريقهم الى ضريح السيده زينب في ريف دمشق
محتجزون نسبت تقارير صحفيه للجيش السوري
الحر تاكيده انهم ضباط في الحرس الثوري
الايراني ومقاتلون بينهم ثمانيه عناصر من
حزب الله كانوا يستعدون للمشاركه في
القتال الى جانب قوات الاسد معلومات ستعقد
في حال ثبتت صحتها جهودا ايرانيه لاطلاق
سراحهم طرقت ابواب انقره والدوحه طلبا
للمساعده في التعامل مع وضعيه ليست سابقه
من نوعها فقد سبق ان تعرض عشرات
الايرانيين للاختطاف في كانون الاول
ديسمبر ليفرج عن معظمهم فيما بعد تجرع
لبنان بدوره شيئا من كاس الاختطاف في
سوريا الاني عشر من شهر ايار مايو الماضي
احد عش زائرا شيعيا لبنانيا يقعون في اسر
جماعه مسلحه في ريف حلب اشترط قادتها
اعتذار زعيم حزب الله حسن نصر الله عن
دعمه للنظام السوري لاطلاق سراحهم لم
يتراجع نصر الله عن مواقفه والمختطف لم
ينالوا الحريه الى ي الناس باتت ايران
تدرك اكثر من اي وقت مضى ان لكل موقف ثمن
في زمن الربيع العربي اختبرت ذلك في سوريا
وفي ليبيا التي اختطف فيها هي الاخرى وفد
للهلال الاحمر الايراني وسط جدل واسع حول
مقدار واشكال التدخل الايراني في الشؤون
العربيه ترى ايران انها انما تدفع
ورعاياها ثمن انحيازها للحقوق العربيه في
وجه السياسات الغربيه ومن يدور في فلكها
في المنطقه بينما لا يجد خصوم طهران في
كشف اليمن ومن قبلها الكويت شبكات تجسس
تعمل لصالح الايرانيين ما يؤكد هذه
الروايه الايرانيه وانما دليلا جديدا يثبت
صحه ما ذهب اليه رئيس البرلمان العربي علي
الدقباسي من ان الوقت حان لموقف عربي موحد
يتصدى لما وصفه بالتدخل الايراني في
الشؤون
العربيه ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من طهران
الدكتور محمد علي مهتدي مستشار مركز الشرق
الاوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن لندن
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي عبد الوهاب بدرخان
اهلا بضينا نبدا من طهران والدكتور
مهتدي دكتور تجاه الاتهامات التي وجهت
لهذه المجموعه
المختطفه ما الراي السائد في
طهران بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني انا
قبل ما اتي الى الاستوديو اتصلت باحد
المسؤولين في منظمه الحج والزياره حيث
اكدوا لي ان هؤلاء مجموعه من الطلاب
الجامعيين وبعض الموظفين في دوائر حكوميه
مختلفه فكونوا رحله سياحيه
لزيارات مقامات اهل البيت في سوريا
و كان في خطتهم بعد زياره سوريا ينتقل الى
لبنان لزياره المعالم السياحيه في لبنان
فهؤلاء مدنيون 100% وليس هناك اي عسكري ا
هذا ما اكدوا لي المسؤولون هنا في طهران
وكما اشرتم في
تقريركم ليست هذه اول مره يختطف او تختطف
مجموعات سياحيه او زوار ايرانيين في في
سوريا فاعتقد ان هناك جهات تريد ان تسيء
الى العلاقات بين الشعب الايراني والشعب
السوري وبصوره عامه بين للعلاقات العربيه
الايرانيه من خلال هذه الاعمال الغير
اخلاقيه ف يعني من المنتظر والمؤمل ان
ان ان يصار الى التنديد بهكذا اعمال غير
اخلاقيه وغير انسانيه ولكن دكتور مهتدي
اليس غريبا في في هذه
الاوضاع المنفجره في في في سوريا ان تقرر
مجموعه القيام برحله سياحيه هكذا بكل
بساطه وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه حذرت
الايرانيين من السفر الى سوريا نظرا
لدقه الاوضاع في سوريا كذلك المسؤول في في
منظمه الحج والزياره اكد لي انهم اوقفوا
جميع الرحلات
السياحيه والزيارات الى سوريا لكن هناك
بعض الاشخاص لا يمكن السيطر عليهم يكونون
رحلات ويستا جرون طائرات او اتوبيسات
ويذهبون الى سوريا لزياره مقامات اهل
البيت والدافع دائما حبهم لاهل البيت نعرف
ان هناك في سوريا مقام السيده زينب بنت
الامام علي بن ابي طالب في مقام السيده
رقيه بنت الامام الحسين بن علي عليه
السلام
وهناك مقامات للصحابه في في في
ا في في في اماكن مختلفه مسجد الاموي في
في باب الصغير هناك رؤوس شهداء كربلاء
فهناك ناس لا لا يعيرون اي اهتمام لهذه
الاحداث ويذهبون الى سوريا والى العراق
كذلك لزياره لزياره المقامات لاهل البيت
والدافع دائما حبهم لاهل
البيت ومدرسه اهل البيت نعم على كل واضح
بان هذه الحجج لم تكن مقنعه ل الجيش
السوري الحر بدليل انه يقول بان هؤلاء من
الحرس الثوري وبانهم من الشبيحه وبانهم
جاؤوا في مهام لمسانده القوات النظاميه
نسال السيد عبد الوهاب بدر خان الى اي مدى
هذه المساله ستلقي مره اخرى بضلال من الشك
الكبير حول الدور المحتمل لايران فيما
يجري داخل
سوريا
يعني من جهه اولى لابد من القول بانه
احتجاز اشخاص ذهبوا
لزياره معالم دينيه في حتى ولو كانت
الظروف
سيئه اذا كانوا فعلا حجاج اذا كانوا فعلا
زوار
مدنيين هو عمل طبعا مستنكر ولا احد يقبله
من جهه اخرى لابد من القول بانه طالما ان
هناك قرار او او او تمني من من وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه بعدم السفر الى سوريا
في هذه الايام لان الاحوال ليست على ما
يرام فوجود هؤلاء وكلهم
رجال بالعاده نرى نرى نرى في لبنان وفي
سوريا
سياحا لاهداف دينيه وهي عباره عن عائلات
هؤلاء كلهم رجال وهذا يعني بدايه للتشكيل
ثم
ان الشريط الذي وزعه الجيش الحر فيه شيء
من ال يعني بعض المعلومات التي ناخذها
طبعا بحذر من دون ان نتهم احدا ولكن وجود
ايرانيين على الارض السوريه في هذه الايام
هو مصدر اشتباه ومصدر تشكيك بدورهم وماذا
يفعلون هنا لان الحكومه الايرانيه موقفها
جدا واضح بالانحياز
لمصلحه النظام ضد الشعب السوري وبالتالي
هذا يعطي بظل حرب اهليه منطق حرب اهليه
تضيع فيه المعايير وبالتالي في ظل وجود
حرب اهليه يعني لم لا يعود مستغربا حصول
مثل هذه الامور بالنسبه الى الدور
الايراني طبعا هو سيبقى دور يعني حتى حتى
اشعار اخر من دون اي تغيير هو راهن على
النظام ويريد لهذا النظام ان يبقى باي شكل
اي من دون شك انه في الفتره الاخيره عندما
دخلت الازمه السوريه في مرحله مرحله حرجه
قد تكون حاسمه اي بدات بدا الدور الايراني
اي
يعني مطلوب منه ان يخطو خطوات اوسع ان ان
يقوم بمبادرات اكبر كان كانت هناك دعوه من
كفي انان ل لاقح ايران في في البحث عن حل
سياسي ولكن الامر كله لم ينجح انما النظام
السوري وخصوصا من فيما بدا من زياره
الوزير وليد المعلم يوم الاحد الماضي كان
واضحا بانه ليس فقط لديه مطالب اي مساعدات
وغيره من من ايران وانما لديه ايضا دعوه
بان ايران يجب ان تساهم مع النظام في
معركته لانهما في معركه واحده ومن يسقط اي
وهو النظام السوري طبعا سيسقط معه الاخر
لانه بالنهايه يراهن عليه في المنطقه
سيسقط الدور الايراني في المنطقه او يضعف
او يتضاءل
و لذلك اي مزيد من الايرانيين على الارض
السوريه يعني مزيد من التورط وبالتالي
فهذا يعطي للجيش السوري الحر امك يعني
مشروعيه بين مزدوجين طبعا ان يقوم بهذه
الاعمال و
ربما يعني روايته عن ان هؤلاء شبيحه
و من الحرس الثوري تبقى على الطاوله حتى
يتم التاكد منها نعم على ذكر الجيش السوري
الحر نحن نحاول منذ بدايه الحلقه ان يكون
معنا احد المسؤولين في الجيش الحر حتى
يقدم لنا على الاقل روايتهم لما جرى
والحجج التي يقدمونها ولكن مع
ذلك دكتور مهتدي ما قاله السيد عبد الوهاب
بدخال الان فعلا يجعل من ذهاب مج مموعه من
الشباب مثل ما ذكرت حتى وان كانت في رحله
خاصه لمجموعه معينه بمبادره شخصيه
منهم تحمل اكثر من نقاط استفهام كيف يمكن
للراي العام المعارض في سوريا وهو المتوج
من ايران او الاطراف الاخرى التي تتهم
ايران بدور ما في سوريا ان تصدق الروايه
التي ذكرتموها قبل
قليل اولا اخ محمد انا ات هل يعقل ان يكون
هناك 47 او
48 عسكريا ايرانيا من الحرس او من البسيج
قبه تابعه ينتقلون الى السيده زينب لزياره
مقام السيده زينب بدون حمايه بدون حراسه
بدون اسلحه بدون شيء يعني هؤلاء مدنيون
واعتبروا ان الجيش السوري استطاع تطهير
دمشق وضواحي دمشق من الارهابيين كما
يسمونهم
ثم انا انا لا لا اوافق مع الاخ عبد
الوهاب من لندن ان ايران تساند النظام
السوري ضد الشعب السوري هذا غير صحيح
وايران اعتقد ان ايران مفتر عليها بالنسبه
لايران يعني من وجهه نظر
الايراني الازمه في سوريا ذات بعدين بعد
داخلي يعني يتعلق بالمطالب الحقه للشعب
السوري في الحريه والديمقراطيه والاصلاح
هنا ايران مع الشعب السوري وتؤيد كل هذه
المطاليب اما البعد الاخر او القسم الاخر
من الازمه تتعلق باجن خارجيه واسقاط
النظام خدمه للاهداف الصهيونيه
والاستراتيجيه الامريكيه وانهاء دور سوريا
في في دعم المقاومه هنا ايران تساند سوريا
امام كل هذه الاجندات
المشبوهه ايران تسند سوريا امام اسرائيل
ايران تساند سوريا امام الاجندات
الامريكيه ايران مع الشعب السوري واعتقد
ان ايران فعلا مفتر عليها في في هذه
الدعايات الرخيصه نعم على كل تمكنا الان
من الحصول عبر سكايب من العاصمه السوريه
دمشق النقيب عبد الناصر شمير قائد لواء
البراه سيد شمير ما الذي جعلكم تجزم بان
هذه المجموعه الايرانيه مجموعه مشبوهه
وليست مجموعه من الز
العاديين السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام قمنا
قمنا بجمع مجموعه من المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه التي حصلنا عليها منذ شهرين
عن توافد مجموعات من ايران من الحرس
الثوري الايراني وجودهم في سوريا مساعده
النظام خدمه له فتم رصد تحركاتهم وتم
القاء القبض عليهم ولكن لنفترض سيد شمير
بان هذه فعلا مجموعه من الحرس الثوري الا
يفترض ان يكون في استقبالهم مسؤولين
عسكريين ان تؤمن لهم حمايه خاصه عبر
سيارات مصفحه وجنود الى اخره هكذا ياتون
وكانهم مجموعه من الشباب في رحله
مدرسيه اولا الحجاج الايرانيين ياتون
زياره الى زياره الاماكن في مدينه دمشق
بشكل عائلي ا ويتنقلون عائليا مجموعه هذه
يتم التموين عليها بحيث ان تبدو للظاهر
انه مجموعه الزوار ايرانيين الى المنطقه
لكن هم موجود معهم وثائق تثبت انهم يعملون
في الحرس الث الايراني ولكن سيد شمير يعني
اذا كان الشخص متجه في مهمه قتاليه لفائده
النظام السوري كيف يحمل معه هويه تثبت
بانه من الحرس الثوري هذه ايضا نقطه تدع
الى التساؤل يعني
ا
عند قبض عليهم
قام مجموعه منهم بالقاء وثائقهم للاسف سيد
شمير هل هل هل يمكن ان سييد شمير هل يمكن
ان تعيد الاجابه من الاول لو سمحت لان
الصوت كان مهتز في البدايه عند عند القاء
عند القاء القبض عليهم قام مجموعه منهم
بالقاء وثائقهم على
واخفائها خوفا من العثور عليها لكن
بالتفتيش والتحقيق مع معهم تبين انهم
يعملون في الحرس الايراني بالاضافه لوجود
تسجيلات صوتيه ومصو تثبت انهم يعملون في
الحرس الثوري نعم على كل بعد بعد فاصل
سنحاول التطرق اكثر لما اشار اليه ضيفان
في البدايه عن الدور الايراني في سوريا
الى اي مدى ما جرى سيعقد اكثر هذا
الجدل المتعلق بدور طهران فيما يجري حاليا
في سوريا لنا عوده بعد فاصل قصير نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في
هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الدور
الايراني في الازمه السوريه في ضوء الجدل
حول احتجاز زوار ايرانيين في سوريا سيد
عبد الوهاب بدرخان
في لندن امام ما ذكر ضيفنا من قائد لواء
البراء عن ما اعتبره ادله تتعلق بهؤلاء
الزوار ماذا تعتقد التداعيات التي يمكن ان
تكون بخصوص هذا
الموضوع يعني اتوقع كما كما تفعل اي جهه
تحتجز مجموعه
بانها يمكن ان تكون لديها مطالب محدده او
انها تريد ان ان
اي يعني تكون لديها مطالب من ايران على اي
حال اذا اذا بزلت مساعي ل الافراج عن
هؤلاء من جان من جانب قطر او تركيا سيتبين
ما هي الشروط ولكن يعني طبعا لابد ان
نتوقع بان بان الجيش الحر سيطلب شروطا ومن
دون شك ب بان بانه ربما طلب مثلا مبادلتهم
ب محتجزين بمطالب معينه
لا يمكن ان اتكه بها ولكن عمليه التوسط
لاطلاق هؤلاء ستكون صعبه اذا كان الجيش
الحر متاكدا منهيه هؤلاء
وبامكانه ايضا ان ان يطلع الراي العام
اكثر
عما يتبينه في استجوابهم عن ما دواعي
وجودهم هناك غير مساله زياره المعالم ال
الدينيه كل هذا ينتظر توضيحات سواء من
جانب الجيش الحر او من جانب ايران التي
يجب ايضا ان
اي يكون لديها الشجاعه لتقول بان هؤلاء
كانوا فعلا بمهمات
وانهم
ربما تنكروا بزي بزي زوار من اناس عاديين
في طريقهم الى الى لبنان وبالتالي في طريق
عودتهم الى الى الى ايران و ولكن على
افتراض ان هؤلاء فعلا جاؤوا في مهمه
قتاليه اي اي نوع من المساعده يمكن ان
تقدمها طهران الان الى النظام السوري وهو
يفترض انه على قدر لا باس به من الخبره في
المسائل القتاليه
والعسكريه صحيح انه لديه كل ما يلزم ل
لممارسه الحرب الدمويه التي يشنها
انما بنفس الوقت في المده الاخيره كانت
لديه كان لديه نقص في عدد القوات التي
يستطيع ان يسق بها ويعتمد عليها كان لديه
ايضا حاجه الى بعض الخبرات استعان ليس فقط
ب بايران وانما ايضا بجماعات من حزب الله
وهذا قد تاكد على الارض من خلال
اي يعني ما يعرفه اللبنانيون عن الاشخاص
الذين شاركوا وقتل بعضهم هناك
واعيد جثمانه الى الى قراه وبالتالي امكن
مع معرفه
ذلك يعني ل لن يستعين بايران من اجل
التشبيح لانه يستعين بايران بخبراتها
العسكريه و وهو يحتاجها
لانه لا يستطيع الثقه بوحدات كامله من
الجيش باعتبار انها ربما اذا اذا اذا زج
بها في الميدان ربما تنشق او
يعني يهرب افرادها او غير ذلك نعم النقيب
عبد الناصر شمير هل فهمتم بالضبط ما هي
طبيعه المهمه التي جاء من اجلها هؤلاء كما
فهمتم نحن الان في صدد التحقيق معهم وعند
انتهاء من التحقيق سيتم نشر كامل الوثائق
والاعترافات العناصر التي تم القبض
عليها طهران طلبت وساطه
قطر وتركيا لاطلاق سراح هؤلاء هل من
تعليق الباب مفتوح
ل كافه الوساطات لكن عند الانتهاء من
التحقيق وعند اثبات ماهيته واعلانها سيتم
التفاوض ب شانهم يعني هل هل لديكم مثلا
تصور ل طبيعه المبادله التي يمكن ان ان
تقومون بها اذا رايتم ذلك
الفكره الاساسيه افهام ايران ان سوريا ارض
محرمه عليها ليس لدينا عداوه مع الشعب
الايراني انما العداوه مع النظام الايراني
يقوم بدعم النظم السوري
بالتقنيات والسلاح
والرجال لذلك نحاول ان نوصل رساله الى
الشعب الايراني
اننا لسنا نناسب له العداء ولكن ادائنا
نتيجه المواقف التي يتخذها النظام
الايراني عندما تم اختطاف مجموعه من
اللبنانيين طلب طلب اعتذار من السيد حسن
نصر الله هل لديكم ربما طلب محدد الان من
طهران عدا هذه الرساله التي اشرت اليها
الان سيتم عرض كافه طلباتنا من الحكومه من
الحكومه الايرانيه ومن النظام السوري في
وقته ان شاء الله الدكتور مهتدي في في
طهران هذه الرساله التي يقول النقيب شمير
بانه
يريدون ايصالها الى طهران كيف تتوقع لها
ان تلقى الصداء
المطلوب والله انا انا لا اعلم انا انا ما
اعلم انا شخصيا عشت في سوريا سنين طويله
واعرف الشعب السوري الشعب سوري شعب محب
للسلام شعب متسامح بكل مكوناته المذهبيه
والدينيه والعرقيه في في في
سوريا ولا اعتقد ان هكذا عمليات غير
اخلاقيه تصدر من فئات من الشعب السوري
اعتقد ان هناك جهات مخابراتيه عالميه
تشتغل في الساحه يعني وفت من هلال الاحمر
الايراني في ضيافه الهلال الاحمر الليبي
فيخطف نهم ويدعون انهم ضباط من الحرس
الثوري او سابقا كان هناك سبعه مهندسين
ايرانيين يعملون في منشات الكهرباء في
مدينه حمص لخدمه الشعب لخدمه الناس
اختطفوه وادعوا انهم ضباط من الحرس الثوري
يعني هذه الاعمال الاجراميه الغير
اخلاقيه يعني حتى دينيا اسلاميا لا لا
يمكن ان ان ان نبرر هكذا اعمال لان كتاب
الله الكريم يقول ولا تجر وزره وزره اخرى
فهذه الاعمال المد في في نهايه الحلقه
دكتور مهتدي بعد اذنك فقط في نهايه الحلقه
نريد ان
نسال النقيب شمير باختصار شديد ما اذا
كانت لديهم شروط محدده لاطلاق سراح
هؤلاء نن شعب متسامح
وشعب
يراعي التنوع المذهبي والديني لكننا ليس
شعب ضعيف يستساغ يستطيع من اراد ان ينطي
عليه
نحن قادرين على الدفاع عن انفسنا ونحن
قادرين باذن الله تعالى عن اسقاط هذا
النظام ولو تحالفت معه الدنيا كلها ما يخص
المطالب فسيتم عرضها ان شاء الله
لاحقا شكرا جزيلا لك النقيب عبد الناصر
شمير قائد لواء البراء كنت معنا من دمشق
شكرا لضيفنا من طهران الدكتور محمد علي
مهتدي مستشار مركز الشرق الاوسط للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه وضيفنا من لندن الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي عبد الوهاب بدر خان بهذا
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم
في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء